Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and just to get
things started in my Game of Thrones Season
4 Countdown I wanted to do a breakdown of
all the best deaths on the show since season
1.
It’s totally in keeping with the Valar Morghulis
theme HBO has been promoting this week with
all the new posters.
Every man must die.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m going to be doing a month long countdown
to the Season 4 premiere with character breakdowns,
best moments and house histories.
I’m also totally open to suggestions if
there’s something you guys really want to
see.
There’ll be at least two videos in the first
week but by the time we get within a week
of the premiere it will be four per week.
Be sure to subscribe for dragons.
Now let’s cue the blood bath, starting with
Season 1 and ending with where we are right
now.
Number 1 - Starting things off on a good beheading.
A patrol of night’s watchmen meet the white
walkers.
This was the very first scene of season 1.
2 - Will pays the price for abandoning his
watch.
This is the last neck Ned Stark’s valyrian
greatsword will touch.
3 - Theon is of actual use and kills the wildling
Stiv to prevent him from capturing Bran.
Kind of ironic, given what would happen later.
4 - Ser Hugh of The Vale runs afoul of The
Mountain’s Lance.
5 - Vardis Egen of The Vale runs afoul of
Bronn and takes a trip down the moon door.
6 - A random wineseller tries to poison Khaleesi
Daenerys and gets dragged to death.
7 - Viserys gets the golden crown he so richly
deserves
8 - Robert Baratheon dies after being poisoned
then skewered by a boar.
9 - Khal Drogo Dies of an infection, and then
later from a ritual gone horribly wrong.
10 - Othor of the Night’s Watch dies and
then returns as a wight.
11 - Mirri Maz Duur is burned at the stake
for pretending to bring back Khal Drogo.
12 - Jory Cassel runs afoul of a two handed
Jaime Lannister
13 - Syrio Forel dies at the hands of the
Kingsguard while defending himself with a
wooden sword.
14 - Ned Stark is beheaded at the behest of
new King Joffrey.
15 - Septa Mordane’s head is put on a spike
also at the behest of new King Joffrey.
16 - Arya Stark lands her very first kill
with her valyrian blade Needle when a stableboy
gets too grabby.
Now begins Season 2
17 - Maester Cressen poisons himself in a
botched attempt to kill Melisandre.
18 - Barra Waters and all of Robert Baratheon’s
Bastards are killed by the Gold Cloaks at
Joffrey’s behest.
19 - The High Septon is killed by a mob going
after King Joffrey.
They even ripped his arm off.
20 - The Hound punches through a peasant’s
chest trying to rape and kill Sansa.
21 - Yoren is killed by Gold Cloaks trying
to capture Gendry.
22 - Lomy Greenhands is also killed by Gold
Cloaks looking for Gendry
23 - Renly Baratheon is killed by Melisandre’s
smoke baby.
24 - The Tickler, Ser Armory Lorch and the
Harenhaal Guards are killed by Jaquen Hagar.
25 - Jon Snow is forced to Kill Qhorin Halfhand.
26 - Irri and Dany’s Khalasar are murdered
in a raid to steal her dragons.
27 - The members of the 13 are murdered by
Pyat Pree
28 - Rodrick Cassel is beheaded by Theon.
29 - Theon murders Billy and Jack in place
of Bran and Rickon.
30 - Maester Luwin is also murdered by Theon.
31 - Matthos Seaworth and almost anyone on
a boat during the battle of Blackwater
32 - Pyat Pree is roasted by Dany’s dragons.
Now we enter Season 3
33 - Hoster Tully died off screen but his
funeral set the tone for the season.
34 - Mero and Prendahl na Ghezn of the Second
Sons are beheaded for plotting against Dany.
35 - Beric Dondarrion is killed by The Hound
and then brought back.
36 - Lord Commander Jeor Mormont is killed
in a Night’s Watch revolt.
37 - Old Craster is murdered by the same renegade
night’s watchmen.
38 - Ros is murdered by Joffery with his crossbow
39 - Krazyns is roasted by Drogon.
39 - Jon Snow kills Orel after he wargs into
his hawk.
40 - Ricard Karstark is beheaded by Robb Stark.
41 - Samwell Kills a White Walker with Dragon
Glass
Now begins the red wedding
42 - Talisa Stark, Robb Stark, Joyeuse Frey,
Catlyn Stark, Grey Wind and the remainders
of the Stark Army.
and finally 43 - Arya Kills one of the Frey
Soldiers after he brags about said Red Wedding.
Feel free to add any big deaths on the show
you think I skipped.
And remember the next video in my season 4
countdown will post next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
let me know what kind of videos you want.
Depending on whether or not I do Oscar videos
on Sunday I’ll try to post it on Monday.
I think it will be either Winds of Winter
or a Q&A.
You can let me know which you prefer.
Right now click here to watch my breakdown
of the last trailer and click here to learn
about my South Park Stick of Truth Giveaway.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!